[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde on
direct ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir une révolution pour la
sécurité en europe la finlande et la
suède s'apprête à adhérer à l'otan les
deux pays ont présenté leur candidature
aujourd'hui dans notre grand décryptage
dans un instant on va revenir avec nos
invités sur les enjeux de cette décision
faut-il craindre les représailles de
vladimir poutine c'est un roman
graphique
désopilant que nous livrent nos deux
grands témoins soir l'histoire de guy
marchand un loser magnifique qui décida
matin de se présenter à l'élection
présidentielle avec ses amis ils
franchiront toutes les étapes
candidature slogan affiche meeting les
deux auteurs le dessinateur xavier gorce
et les selistes rachel kahn signe cette
partie de campagne aux édition de
l'observatoire ils sont avec nous ce
soir enfin nous retrouverons nous
affranchit pour leur parti pris ce soir
le carnet de campagne zelda monde un
gala sur les législatives le coup de
gueule de fatiha boudjellal sur lafertin
à boisset puis leur garde isabelle
lasserre sur la reddition des héros
d'ukrainiens d'azur ce talent voilà pour
le menu du parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs qui aurait imaginé il ya
encore quelques mois un tel renversement
stratégique la finlande et la suède
candidate à l'entrée dans l'otan quelles
conséquences pour nous européens et pour
la russie on en parle avec vous ce soir
elena volochine bonsoir et merci d'être
là grand reporter pour france 24
ancienne correspondante à moscou vous
avez passé dix ans spécialiste de la
russie bonsoir et charles berling choix
mais il ya un bienvenue sur ce plateau
visage familier de cette émission dans
laquelle vous êtes chroniqueur
correspondant à paris pour le média
suisse alémanique comme on dit blick
bonsoir philippe martin geniez bienvenue
à vous spécialiste des questions
européennes vous enseignez à sciences po
et à l'inalco et puis on attend dans
quelques minutes le général dominique
trinquons qui va nous rejoindre sur ce
plateau ancien chef de la mission
militaire française à l'onu mais d'abord
pour tout comprendre de ce qui se passe
dans le nord de l'europe le billet de
l'ami blakowski si j'ai bien compris
c'est à lui
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane bon sans rire yann
bonsoir à tout en fait et à tous si j'ai
bien compris ce soir si j'ai bien
compris myriam vladimir poutine a
ressuscité l'otan vous souvenez qu'en
2019 macron avait décrété la mort
cérébrale de beau temps et bien voilà
c'était lectra choc de l'invasion de
l'ukraine qui réveille l'alliance
puisque la finale la finlande qui était
notre depuis 75 ans la suède qui était
notre depuis 200 ans d'instance ont
décidé de rejoindre une alliance
militaire en l'occurrence l'otan vous
croyez vraiment poutine s'apprête à
attaquer la finlande et la suède pas du
tout alors pas du tout ça me paraît
complètement impossible mais c'est
exactement pareil pour l'ukraine donc
comment décrire finlandais est forcément
le côté c'est pas possible ils ont du
mal à y croire surtout que cela leur est
déjà arrivé regardez il ya 1200 1300 km
de frontière et en 1939 staline avait
tenté d'annexer la finlande de l'urss
donc à l'époque il s'était défendu un
peu comme les ukrainiens en infériorité
il avait dû céder du territoire puis
aussi accepter de ne s'engager dans
aucune alliance militaire en tout cas
pas l'otan dont il ya un vrai tournant
historique pour l'asf est pour l'instant
langue le risque c'est de s'exposer
représailles des russes qui commence
elle a réussi neuf en plus d'électricité
à la finlande mais la première ministre
finlandaise
ben est prête à tenir tête à poutine on
les écoute oui nous devons être courage
et dans quel état place face à ces
situations et bien sûr la finlande
considère tout cela de son propre point
de vue en ce qui concerne notre propre
sécurité nous voulons nous assurer que
ce qui se passe en ukraine ils se
reconnaissent plus jamais atteint nommé
gagnent alors la finlande pourrait se
sentir un peu protégés déjà puisqu'elle
fait partie de l'union européenne mais
bien sûr
tout le monde rigole oui sauf que c'est
très sympa de pouvoir compter sur 27
petites armes est un qui se donnerait la
main pour défendre la finlande mais les
finlandais préfère quand même une bonne
grosse armée regarder ses statistiques
donc cl dépenses militaires de l'otan
voyez qu'en fait d'alliance militaire
les etats-unis sont le centre et domine
écrase l'ensemble delà de cette alliance
pour info les dépenses militaires
américaines ces trois fois celle de la
chine dix fois celle de la russie donc
c'est rassurant d'être avec les
américains pour le comprend et et
vadimir poutine alors quelle réaction
ville est contrarié parce qu'il avait
dit comme but de guerre empêcher
l'ukraine de rejoindre l'otan pour se
protéger au sud et hop voilà que non
seulement il a du mal avec l'ukraine
mais en plus ça craque au nord puisque
c'est la suède c'est la finlande qui
veulent rejoindre maintenant l'otan et
puis il ya une tendance depuis 49 que
l'otan ne cesse de s'élargir regardez
cette carte oui au départ c'étaient les
pays fondateurs en 49 sont des pieds
enfoncés donc c'est en fait une alliance
ou une dizaine de pays européens sont
sous la protection des états unis
militaire des états unis par rapport à
la menace soviétique sauf que l'urss
c'est fini depuis 91 et tous les pays
qui était sous domination soviétique up
son revenu dans le giron de l'otan dont
ils étaient douze ils sont 30 donc c'est
le cauchemar de la demi-heure poutine
s'était largement permanent de l'otan on
croyait donc qu'il allait très énervé
surprise il a pris ça plutôt calmement
finlande suède
je voudrais vous informer chers
collègues que la russie n'a aucun
problème avec ces états un tel
élargissement de l'otan à ces pays ne
constitue pas une menace immédiate pour
nous la russie mais le déploiement
d'infrastructures militaires sur les
territoires de ces pays entraînera bien
sûr une réponse
on va revenir évidemment sur cette
réaction un peu étonnante du maître du
kremlin en france qu'elles sont quelles
sont les réactions à cette date-là c'est
le même clivage qu'à la présidentielle
le président de la cre ont apporté son
soutien à la finlande elle se fait pour
qu'elle intègre l'otan tandis que marine
le pen elle ben elle est beaucoup plus
réticent c'est bon ça d'un mauvais oeil
pour résumer sa position c'est c'est
bien beau de soutenir les ukrainiens
c'est bien gentil faudrait quand même
pas que ça nous entraîne dans une
troisième guerre mondiale on écoute
est-ce que l'adhésion de ces deux pays à
l'otan va nous permettre d'avancer vers
la paix voilà parce qu'en fait c'est la
seule question qu'il faut se poser est
ce que élargir l'otan aujourd'hui fait
avancer la paix alors réponse est ce que
ça l'élargissement des risques créés la
guerre écoutez il s'est rendu pensa
s'inquiètent en tout cas n'est pas la
société henri guaino qui a écrit une
tribune qui fait pas mal parler
qui disait nous marchons vers la guerre
comme des somnambules et voulait dire
par là qu'ils avaient sorte d' escalade
où chacun s'inquiétait de l'adversaire
et que l'on pouvait finalement son de
vouloir
finir par déclencher une guerre alors
est ce qui fallait élargir notre temps
est ce qu'il faut élargir le temps à
l'aspm et à la finlande je ne sais pas
mais vous êtes il ya des peintres merci
beaucoup stéphane richer vernis je vais
partir avec vous de cette carte on
commence par la finlande on a vu les
1300 km 2 de frontière commune c'est une
situation évidemment stratégique
objectivement les finlandais
ont raison de s'inquiéter ou pas ils ont
raison de s'inquiéter ils ont d'autant
plus raison de s'inquiéter que pour la
première fois dans l'histoire récente de
la langue il y avait un consensus
favorable à l'adhésion à l'otan ces
salles élément nouveau parce qu'il faut
bien comprendre que la neutralité de ces
deux pays la suède et la finlande est
une neutralité qui était ancien mais qui
a eu longtemps le soutien de ces deux
populations or aujourd'hui les deux
gouvernements suédois et finlandais
constate tous les sondages le prouvent
que leur population a peur
mais donc ils en sont dans l'otan s'est
pas non plus complètement lié à cette
invasion ça commençait déjà à se poser
cette question avant non il ya une
énorme différence et quand même une
énorme différence entre se poser la
question et apporter la réponse est
effectivement la question était là la
réponse a été apportée ce que je voulais
dire c'est que la neutralité était au
fond un élément politique essentielle de
ces deux pays c'est ça faisait partie de
leur adn de leur identité mais
malheureusement compte tenu des
circonstances la population a changé
d'avis et il faut bien dire aussi que la
finlande avait fait un premier pas vous
l'avez dit notamment en achetant des
f-35 américain donc en se rapprochant
militairement des états unis la grande
question va être de savoir s'il est
possible d'être dans l'otan sans
infrastructure militaire est ce que
vladimir poutine en temps par
infrastructures militaires qu'on veut en
parler le cas de la france puisqu'en
france il n'y a pas de base américaine
on peut très bon peut tout à fait
imaginer que ça fait partie du deal que
la suède et la finlande vont tenter
d'obtenir et de et de négocier patrick
martin j ai parlé de révolution
ça vous semble approprié a complètement
c'est une révolution politique
géopolitique stratégique évidemment le
terme de finlande isation pendant des
dizaines d'années
valorisation ça veut dire ça voulait
dire qu'une démocratie un pays
démocratique avait des libertés proche
de la russie de l'union soviétique à
l'époque et bien s'abstenait de
d'elle-même la classe politique de
critique et l'union soviétique et par
exemple la finlandisation faut savoir
une chose c'est qu'il y avait même un
texte de loi qui pénalisait des articles
de presse qui critiquait l'union
soviétique des six films
cinématographiques qui était regardée
comme anti soviétique ce lait n'était
pas possible c'était une autocensure et
enfin la finlande ne pouvait pas se
prononcer sur les conflits
internationaux
donc c'est une véritable
solution politique comme vous l'avez dit
plus de 70% de la population adhère à ce
projet oui parce que ont en réalité on a
fermé pendant des années les yeux sur le
total totalitarisme du kremlin qui
montait et aujourd'hui quand on dit que
la russie de la demiap août ils sont
capables d'envahir l'ukraine et bien
finalement ils se disent qu'eux aussi
ils seraient capables d'envahir la
finlande bonsoir général trinquant ravi
de vous retrouver sur ce plateau
dominique 30 ans ancien chef de la
mission militaire française aux nations
unies sur la menace militaire russe que
ce soit en finlande ya déjà eu des
exercices militaires peut-être pas le
long côté russe de la frontière
finlandaise mais près des pays baltes
c'est pas très loin et puis sur la suède
l'île de gotland j'ai découvert l'île de
gotland personnellement va vous montrer
la carte là on re militariste parce
qu'il ya eu la petite enclave de
kaliningrad qui est russe des avions
posté donc la menace allait elle existe
oui à menacer l' existence
il faudrait rappeler
pardonnez-moi de arrivé un petit peu en
retard mais là la finlande faut se
rappeler que sa neutralité elle a été
imposée après la guerre d'hiver de 39-40
dans laquelle elle a très bien combattu
contre la russie en fin de l'union
soviétique à l'époque et infligé des
grosses pertes et ensuite il ya eu un
accord en 48 dans lequel elle s'est fait
imposer la neutralité donc ce n'est pas
une volonté de sa part et aujourd'hui
c'est sa volonté
expliqué sur la suède ait des vols
réguliers
la mer baltique comme vous le voyez
lorsque la suède et la finlande ont
auront rejoint l'otan en fait il restera
saint pétersbourg et kaliningrad russe
tout le reste ça sera l'otan donc ça
sera j'allais dire un oui un lac un lac
otanien et il y avait toujours des
menaces alors sur le long de la
frontière finlandaise 1600 km bien sûr
il ya toujours eu des problèmes et
avec la suède il ya eu des problèmes on
parle des avions là aussi mais des
problèmes de sous marins près de l'île
de gotland il ya quelques quelques mois
maintenant et a eu des problèmes avec
des sous marins donc on voit que ces
deux pays même s'il avait la neutralité
et c'était historique pour la suède
imposé pour la finlande l'historique
pour la suède mais ils ont toujours été
en paix armée si j'ose dire là la
finlande un système j'ai eu la chance
d'aller visiter ces deux pays de voir le
défense finlandaise je peux vous dire
qu'il se souvienne la guerre d'hiver est
en gros il disait que les russes n'y
reviennent pas parce que on se prépare y
compris sur le plan maritime avec des
choses très intéressantes comme des
fortins qui sont au bord de la mer avec
des missiles anti navires etc en fait
c'est très très organisé et la suède
faut le rappeler a remis la conscription
en place justement parce qu'elle sentait
la menace venir il ya un petit moment et
donc ce sont des pays qui était en paix
armée en fait on s'interroge sur la
réaction de la dioxine on peut dire
merci poutine l'otan et plus renforcée
que jamais ça on a compris mais pourquoi
diable finalement dit il que c'était pas
si grave à ses yeux alors il ya quelques
conditions on va revoir ce qu'il a dit
il a prévenu explicitement les membres
de l'otan l'expansion des
infrastructures militaires sur ce
territoire provoquerait une réponse de
notre part mais en même temps et bien
cet élargissement ne constitue pas une
menace immédiate pour nous vous avez été
surprise par la réponse de poutine ou
pas non pas tellement j'évite d'être
surprise par quoi que ce soit donc je
les aimais routine dernièrement parce
que si on y est on y gagne quelques
cheveux blancs disons que vladimir
poutine in fine y être surpris ni par
surpris par ce qu'il dit parce qu'en
fait il dit absolument ce qu'il veut et
cela ne veut absolument rien dire il
aurait il peut réagir comme ça il peut
dire exactement l'inversé le résultat
sera exactement le même c'est-à-dire que
leur art de là la raison quoi c'est
rappelons-nous jusqu'à la dernière
minute avant l'invasion de l'ukraine il
parler d'hystérie occidentale disant que
non la rue si j'amène envahir et
l'ukraine et c'est donc aujourd'hui il
peut dire que le temps que la finlande
et la suède ne représente pas une menace
il peut le penser finalement et c'est
sans doute vrai c'est à pires craintes
un l'élargissement de l'otan qui est en
train de se dérouler sans interruption
purement rhétorique et propagandistes
qui est de dire la russie est sur la
défensive face à l'otan est en réalité
pour justifier une politique qui est
offensive comme on le sait vladimir
poutine inverse totalement les rôles
donc évidemment plus les temps plus le
peloton en gagne deux pays plus cela
justifie ce discours propagandistes qui
est de dire la russie est menacé par
l'otan etc il ne faut surtout pas tomber
dans ce panneau et dire que oui parce
que la suède et la finlande a gagné on
passait quand ça veut dire que il menace
la russie et donc les émirs poutine ça
n'arrange pas ses affaires en fait cela
ne change rien elles changent rien à
dire cela n'arrange ni ne dérange ces
affaires lui sa priorité clairement et
c'est là où effectivement il dit sans
doute vrai quand il dit que ce n'est pas
une menace parce que ce n'était pas sa
priorité avant ça ne l'est pas non plus
maintenant là il se concentre à essayer
de ne pas perdre la guerre en ukraine
qui est temps qu'il est temps qui est un
désastre militaire absolue qui est un
fiasco absolu et c'est une catastrophe
pour lui c'est potentiellement une
catastrophe pour son régime il en va
potentiellement de la survie de son
régime donc c'est clair que sa priorité
ce n'est pas du tout la suède et la
finlande alors après pour vous répondre
il intègre l'otan est ce que c'est un
problème pour lui je ne pense pas que
vladimir poutine pense réellement que la
finlande et la suède et parce que il y a
donné entière en coupe les longues
carrières plus longues mais c'est
ignoble je ne pense pas qu'il voit
davantage de menaces militaires puisque
l'otan mais pas dans une stratégie
d'attaqué vis-à-vis de la rue très cher
vers les ya quand même eu des sanctions
poutine il a coupé l'électricité au
finlandais comment comprendre il va
comment comprendre tout simplement parce
qu'il doit de toute façon malgré sa
déclaration il doit montrer qu'il a des
moyens de rétorsion il doit prouver
qu'il reste l'homme fort de la région et
que face à l'otan il a le moyen de faire
monter les enchères sécuritaire la
difficulté dans ce cas là elle est
double d'abord si on compare certes il
n'y a pas d'intention menaçante du tout
de la suède de la finlande vis de la
russie mais je parle sous le contrôle du
général l'appareil militaire suédois et
finlandais c'est quand même tout à fait
autre chose que l'appareil militaire
l'ukrainien vous venez de le dire à
propos des défenses autour de la
baltique la deuxième chose c'est qu'il
ya quand même des nuances et j'y venais
tout à l'heure c'est à dire est ce que
oui ou non ces deux pays accueillons des
bases militaires américaines provisoire
temporaires comme le font certains pays
ou bien permanente là
sur la filiation des censeurs il ya
sûrement un curseur que ni stockholm ni
helsinki ne sont prêts à franchir donc
je pense qu'on va rester dans une
intégration dans l'otan mais sur la base
du dispositif militaire existants de ces
deux pays oui il faut quand même attiré
l'attention sur un double langage on a
vu la demiap hawtin qui dit quelque
chose en ce1 en à son ministre sergueï
lavrov qui dit des choses encore plus
dur rappelez vous son intervention dans
l'académie diplomatique lundi ils disent
être carrément qu'il s'agissait d'une
guerre hybride de l'occident contre la
russie qu'il s'agissait effectivement
d'une ressource phobie que le droit
international et est pierrick s'agissait
d'un diktat de washington et enfin il a
dit qu'il s'agissait d'un nouveau d'une
nouvelle architecture internationale et
donc on voit bien aujourd'hui qui sont
très inquiets même si évidemment ils ne
pourront pas faire grand chose mais
comme vous dites tout à fait justement
lorsque vladimir poutine dit quelque
chose il ne faut pas le croire parce que
il dit cela ça gagne la preuve son
ministre des affaires étrangères dit
notre choses qui sont parfois plus dur
que vladimir poutine il semblerait qu'il
ya quand même une hutte au sein du
régime sur ce discours qui est d'autant
plus dure et par conséquent on voit bien
aujourd'hui que eh bien il n'est pas
très crédible et vous dit effectivement
il y aura des conséquences tout dépendra
de ce que cette adhésion signifiera sur
le plan militaire est ce qu'il y aura
une accumulation d'armes ou pas en tout
cas que ce qu'il s'agisse de vladimir
poutine de sergueï lavrov il y aura des
conséquences sur l'armement qui sera
installé pour la danse et plus vous le
demandez très simplement poutine at il
peur de l'otan sur ce que dit sergueï
lavrov sergueï lavrov répète toujours la
même chose ce sont exactement les mêmes
la même rhétorique les mêmes termes de
guerre et bride de guerre de proxy de
troisième but voire de troisième guerre
mondiale etc contre la russie ça c'est
absolument pas nouveau c'est quelque
chose qu'ils disent tout le temps
vladimir poutine le dit aussi il n'y a
rien de nouveau là-dedans ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que vladimir poutine
juste avant de lancer l'invasion de
l'ukraine en décembre dernier il a émis
des exigences sans précédent vis-à-vis
de washington et de l'otan ce que la
russie a qualifié de garanties de
sécurité où ils exigeaient pour la
première fois que l'otan retire ses
troupes des militarise tous les pays
qu'il a militarisé et qu'ils ont intégré
depuis 1997 que l'ukraine soit un pays
neutre et c est ensuite étant donné
qu'il n'a pas obtenu ce qu'ils voulaient
parce que par là-même parle même temps
il y avait cette concentration militaire
que tout le monde se demande ds que ce
serait juste montrer les muscles
réellement est-ce qu'il avait une
intention militaire derrière évidemment
il n'a pas changé d'avis à la dernière
minute en décidant d'envahir l'ukraine
aujourd'hui les renseignements et tout
le tout le récit de ce conflit même
depuis 2014 montre que c'était une
stratégie qui était déjà préparé de
longue date et c'est tout le monde a été
surpris par le timing c'est à dire qu'il
le fasse maintenant mais c'est clair que
c'était déjà en préparation et donc on
voit que c'est rhétorique que c'était
finalement un prétexte c'est à dire que
ce n'est pas parce que tout d'un coup
l'otan n'a pas cédé il a volontairement
émis des exigences inacceptables
vis-à-vis de washington de l'otan pour
justifier son attaque dont ce que je
changerais vous nous mettez en garde ne
fait pas c'est votre l'argumentaire
exactement de poutine s'est orienté vers
maintenant je gardais les lettres une
chance très idéologique général
trinquant oui je suis tout à fait
d'accord sur le fait de la rhétorique
sur laquelle on doit apporter une
attention relative en revanche et je
suis aussi d'accord sur le fait que vous
parliez de la peur de l'otan de poutine
en fait il a peur pour son régime
aujourd'hui parce qu'il est en train de
pourparlers en termes vulgaires
militaires de se prendre une bâche et il
va falloir qu'il justifie ça devant son
peuple et ça ça va être compliqué et
quand on parle de guerre asymétrique
vous rappelez français on est bien placé
pour le savoir la guerre asymétrique des
russes on la connaît on a collé au mali
on la reconnaît en centrafrique on
connaît l'influencé actuellement en
bosnie herzégovine auprès des serbes on
connaît toute cette cette guerre
asymétrique donc le problème c'est que
il a il doit sauver son régime et pour
cela faire faire croire encore de la
rhétorique qu'il a remporté une grande
victoire qu'il a sauvé qui l'a libéré
les camarades et ses acteurs mais ne
nous leurrons pas il continuera à nous
attaquer de façon asymétrique sur
d'autres termes ça vient de se passer le
malick et
mon coeur saigne pour le mali les
pauvres ils se mettent dans une
situation épouvantable et tous a poussé
par la rhétorique russe donc je crois
que on n'est pas au bout d'un
renversement important et on verra ce
qu'il adviendra en russie alors je vous
ramène à la procédure d'adhésion de
l'otan mais je vous redonne la parole
dans un instant pour intégrer l'otan il
faut l'unanimité
déjà quelques pays comme la turquie met
certaines conditions voire traîne plutôt
les pieds pourquoi on voit cela avec
clément père dont
le coup d'envoi est donné la suède et la
finlande entre désormais dans un
processus d'adhésion à l'otan qui
comprend plusieurs étapes la première ce
sont les pourparlers d'adhésion ils ont
lieu au siège de l'otan à bruxelles de
réunion la première portera sur les
aspects politiques et militaires la
seconde plus technique sera concentrée
sur les questions juridiques
ce seront en quelque sorte les deux
grands oraux pour la finlande et la
suède qui devront convaincre qu'ils
répondent aux exigences de l'otan
notamment jouir d'un système politique
démocratique fonctionnel traiter les
minorités de manière équitable ou encore
s'engager à régler les conflits de
manière pacifique une fois ces
pourparlers terminé place à la
ratification par les pays membres se
sont à chaque fois les gouvernements qui
donne le feu vert les procédures varie
d'un pays à l'autre aux états unis il
faut une majorité des deux tiers au
sénat au royaume uni à linverse aucun
vote formel n'est requis en france
l'assemblée nationale doit ratifier le
protocole d'adhésion les demandes
doivent être acceptés à l'unanimité des
30 états membres pour l'heure un seul
pays émet des réserves il s'agit de la
turquie qui reproche aux deux pays
d'héberger sur leur sol des opposants
qu'ankara juge comme des terroristes
si le protocole va au bout la demande
doit enfin être notifiée au gouvernement
américain qui est le dépositaire du
traité de l'atlantique nord la
ratification prend entre six mois et un
an jens stoltenberg le secrétaire
général de l'otan a déjà indiqué qu'il
souhaitait un processus rapide et
efficace
il est en marche ce processus d'adhésion
c'est s'est fait quasiment pas réservé
les buy donadi ce soir washington
travaillera avec la finlande et la suède
pendant le processus d'adhésion est ce
qu'on peut croire un veto turc ou pas
les conditions d'adhésion elles sont
remplies clairement c'est évident venir
le reste le grand oral les premiers
ministres tout ça on est dans le décorum
politique nécessaire mais il est évident
que tant sur le plan militaire que sur
le plan politique respect de la
démocratie etc il n'y a pas de problème
après est ce que la turquie est en
mesure aujourd'hui de maintenir son veto
dans disons l'année qui va venir qui
sera l'année des examens cette adhésion
je crois que ça va dépendre énormément
de la situation sur le terrain mon
impression c'est que de toute manière
l'intérêt stratégique de la turquie
n'est pas de s'opposer à une extension
de l'otan c'est plutôt de demander
quelque chose en échange dans le
dialogue et
dans le dialogue qu'elle a souvent avec
les états unis et il y a quand même en
arrière-pensée de la turquie toujours un
autre pays c'est son voisin la grèce
donc c'est plutôt ce type de
négociations qu erdogan va essayer
d'avoir au sein de l'otan que de
s'opposer à l'entrée de la suède de la
finlande à brême combien de temps alors
je reviens simplement sur la turquie
parce que c'est un point important
pourquoi président erdogan à des
élections au printemps 2023 et donc le
thème du pkk est un thème extrêmement
fort en turquie donc les kurdes le
particulier exactement par doro les
kurdes assurent les kurdes pkk quand
même différent ça fait partie de la
rhétorique d'erdogan cette fois ci non
mais le lait le pkk est un mouvement
terroriste pour les turcs qui a tué 40
mille personnes en turquie et donc ils
ne peuvent pas admettre qu'on protège le
pkk avec la position à protéger en suède
je suis désolé certes il permet sa ferme
asie dont ces gens parce que nos mères
et donc et donc la position qu'a le
président erdogan aujourd'hui est en
relation avec son échéance électorale de
2023 donc il parle fort au sein de la
turquie pour bien se placer et donc le
reste c'est de la négociation avec la
suède et avec la faillite et l'italie un
peu avec les états unis vous avez raison
sur qu'est-ce qui va pouvoir
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ce que je
dis voilà donc mais c'est vraiment sa
position interne du calendrier électoral
turc erdogan fait la politique on peut
s'attendre à une adhésion rapide à
quelle échéance moi je crois une très
rapide alors on a oublié dire aussi que
la souhaite comme la finlande font
partie du partenaire pour la paix de
l'otan donc on travaille avec eux depuis
très longtemps donc tu
sur le plan militaire dans les exercices
de l'otan il ya quasiment toujours des
finlandais et des suédois donc on sur le
plan militaire on sait très bien
travaillé ensemble voilà je il ne faut
pas oublier non plus que dans cette
période et ça a été rappelé je crois par
le président macron ils font partie de
l'europe article 42 7 de l'europe qui
est un peu l'équivalent de l'article 5
sauf que évidemment dans l'article 5 il
ya les américains en plus donc voilà
j'ai dit que s'agissant des qte
franchement c'est bien plus subtil que
ça à aucun moment la chaîne à protéger
des terroristes parce que erdogan
considère que tous les kurdes sont des
terroristes potentiels de quoi parle
monsieur erdogan qui lui persécutent les
kurdes depuis le début dans son régime
eh bien ce sont des 33 réfugiés
politiques qui sont dans ces pays dont
il demande d'extradition est
naturellement si le pkk est classé dans
la liste des organisations terroristes
tel n'est pas le cas des réfugiés kurdes
politique avoué très clair donc c'est du
chantage encore une fois c'est de la
désinformation de la part de monsieur
erdogan qui bien sûr ne s'opposera pas
selon moi à cela faut également dire que
au sein du parlement suédois il ya aussi
une cinq ou six députés qui sont
d'origine kurde et donc monsieur ado
gagnent comme vous savez a complètement
sanctionner ça mais c'est de la
rhétorique
poutine fait de la rhétorique erdogan
ont fait également je voudrais vous
entendre sur ce débat en france là qui
dit occupent les colonnes ces derniers
jours on en parlait tout à l'heure avec
stéphane blakowski cette tribune d'henri
guaino au fond sur l'opportunité réelle
pour la paix puisque c'est le mot qui
est prononcée on a entendu aussi dans la
bouche de marine le pen
de faire rentrer ces deux pays dans
l'otan qu'est-ce qu'il traduit ce débat
selon vous est un nabot chine alors sur
le fait de ne pas humilier la russie et
c'est au fond de dire c'est à dire que
montrer ces deux pays c ont reculé face
à un objectif de paix après cette guerre
d'après le premier réflexe profondément
russe lorsque vladimir poutine a
prononcé ce terrifiant discours du 22
février où on avait compris qu'il allait
faire la guerre en ukraine et où les les
eaux que les européens ont décidé de se
réunir pour discuter de sanctions parce
qu'ils n'avaient pas encore compris le
message jusqu'au bout mon premier
réflexe a été de dire mais pourvu qu'il
n'y ait pas la guerre donnez lui ce
qu'il veut surtout ne fait rien parce
que j'étais tellement terrifié à l'idée
qu'il y ait une guerre à grande échelle
en ukraine et que la russie à gré ce
pays que je me disais mais il faut le
laisser faire et en fait la question
allait-elle elle était là quand je dis
qu'il ne faut pas tomber dans le panneau
du discours de vladimir poutine c'est ça
c'est à dire que cette notion d'
humiliations de pays humilié par
l'occident etc c'est ce qui sert à
justifier une chose terrible comme comme
l'agression de ce pays et une fois qu'on
a franchi ce cap de terreur face à lui
est bien une fois que les occidentaux se
sont engagés à faire gagner
militairement l'ukraine parce que
l'ukraine ne pourrait pas remporter
cette guerre militairement s'il n'y
avait pas les livres les livraisons dern
d'armes et l'aide financière occidentale
et bien à ce moment là c'est soit on va
jusqu'au bout soit on fait comme à
munich en 1938 face à hitler et on se
dit bon bah on sait de la
tchécoslovaquie on s'aide l'ukraine on
ne s'engage pas et on sacrifie l'ukraine
au profit d'une paix en europe il est et
il est là le débat s'est pas d'humilier
ou de ne pas humilier vladimir poutine
la notion d' humiliation c'est encore
une fois tomber dans ce panneau qui dit
parce que l'occident nous humilient
parce que l'occident cherche à nous
détruire finalement en tant que
civilisation et bien nous nous sommes
légitimes à nous défendre c'est ce que
dit vladimir poutine c'est faux réservé
les est-ce qu'il est légitime ce débat
selon vous comment c'est à dire
attention la france doit mettre son veto
c'est ce que dit henri guaino à l'entrée
de ces deux pays dans dans l'otan je
rappelle qu'il ya eu beaucoup de débats
aussi ce qu'on appelle l' architecture
de sécurité
pensée dans les années 90 avec l'idée
que peut-être il fallait y intégrer la
russie ou en tout cas dialoguer avec
elle qu'est ce que vous en pensez je
pense que sur cette tribune henri guaino
à tort sur la forme et il a tort sur le
fond d'abord il a tort sur la forme
parce que c'est pas du tout des
somnambules les pays en ce moment tous
les pays savent ce qu'ils font personne
ne marche en dormant tout le monde on
peut critiquer éventuellement une marche
éveillé mais tout le monde est tout à
fait conscient des responsabilités et
des risques dont déjà ça c'est une
erreur et il a tort sur le fond parce
que la guerre est déclenchée il s'agit
pas d'aller vers la guerre il s'agit de
répondre à une guerre et donc quand la
guerre est déclenchée eh bien on peut
pas vous reprocher je dirais d'y aller
la guerre a été déclenchée donc là je
crois vraiment qu'ils se trompent par
contre il y à un débat à voir et ce
débat il est douloureux pour l'europe
parce que le fait est que les pays
européens l'union européenne est
aujourd'hui otage d'une certaine manière
de ce conflit parce que l'indépendance
stratégique volonté affichée par
emmanuel macron elle devient de plus en
plus difficiles il faut bien le
reconnaître parce que quand deux pays
comme la suède et la finlande rejoigne
le temps avec la volonté de se
rapprocher des états unis vous imagine
c'est l'otan et pour les gens bien que
les états unis les états unis vont en
profiter c'est normal c'est la première
puissance et c'est eux qu'on vient
chercher pour la défense de l'europe
donc oui il y a un problème avec l'otan
je crois qu'il faut le dire mais pour le
moment c'est l'otan qui a les clés et le
verrou été effet est assez fermé il est
dans les mains de washington
plusieurs points le premier point vous
parlez de la tribune de monsieur
guéhenno et moi je vous parlerai de la
tribune en réponse de bruno tertrais 1
qui s'opposent à un certain nombre de
points que vous venez de souligner
d'une certaine façon sur la suède et la
finlande poutine a répondu il a dit que
c'était pas grave on s'avance pas
peuvent plus vers la guerre pas ce
qu'est la suède et la finlande dans
l'otan enfin le dernier point sur
sur l'union européenne
question je partage pas tout à fait
votre point de vue parce que évidemment
aujourd'hui tout le monde se regroupe
autour du parapluie américain d'accord
mais faut rappeler que
l'europe les européens le pilier
européen de l'otan évincé la majorité de
l'europe et c'est l'europe qui se
regroupent la temporairement qu'est ce
que deviendra l'administration
américaine dans trois ans moi j'en sais
rien et je rappellerai ce que disait
monsieur trump à propos de le temps et
l'article 5 donc l'europe pour vous et
un bouclier qui s'appelle l'otan c'est
la défense européenne et c'est très bien
comme ça mais l'autonomie l'autonomie
européenne ça veut dire quoi ça veut pas
dire pas d'autant ça veut dire que quand
on a besoin de l'otan on est avec le
temps et quand on peut faire sans l'otan
parce que les états unis sont pas
intéressés veulent pas etc on va pouvoir
le faire de façon autonome est ce que
devrait donc c'est sévère
on peut pas faire de manière autonome
non non mais là je suis d'accord face à
face face à la russie sans l'otan et
celle autant le le bien sûr mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que les européens
doivent pas oublier la position
spécifique des américains qui se
retourne plus tôt vers l'asie et ils
doivent profiter de cette crise pour
monter en puissance mais dans beaucoup
de domaines l'interopérabilité
l'armement et c'est pour vraiment
asseoir leur autonomie à l'est le mot de
la fin patrick mathé général je suis
d'accord qu'aujourd'hui le parapluie
clairement américains ce qui ne veut pas
dire que l'europe ne doit pas s'afficher
et d'ailleurs il ya un grand progrès
puisque au mois de mars l'europe a parlé
d'une boussole de stratégique et que
dans les années qui viennent l'europe
devra renforcer son autonomie
stratégique mais pour l'instant ce n'est
pas encore le cas le cas et ce n'est pas
encore suffisant c'est un pas vers une
défense européenne a longtemps eh bien
on va s'arrêter là merci infiniment
merci d'être venus débattre sur le
plateau d'el cp on va partir à présent à
la rencontre de guy marchand avec un thé
s'il vous plaît il habite une ville
moyenne au bord de loi au bord de la
loire et les chômeurs sans
responsabilité puis ils adorent ils
adorent écouter claude nougaro toute la
journée il s'est lancé dans un défi fou
devenir président de la république le
dessinateur xavier gorce et l'essayiste
rachel kahn nous livre un roman
graphique désopilant qui en dit long sur
la société sur la politique ça s'appelle
une partie de campagne c'est publié aux
édition de l'observatoire et avant d
accueillir marque au pommier leur
adresse cette invitation
si on vous invitera chaque année xavier
gorce ces pourparlers présidentielle et
campagne électorale faites confiance
à une tortue électorale ça gâche comme
moi le peuple
ces valeurs sont des stars alors non pas
cette présidentielle mais celle à
laquelle nous avons tous échappé celle
que vous nous racontez dans votre livre
l'histoire d'un homme qui un beau matin
en se rasant tiens tiens se voit comme
l'homme providentiel
guy marchand veut devenir président de
la république mais lui ne chante pas
contrairement aux crooners
st
rachel kahn diego tv est désormais un
livre en commun les cris pour rachel
kahn le dessin pour xavier corse avec
humour et un regard malicieux vous
raconter les aventures décalées de guy
marchand et de sa bande de copains
novice en politique
leur méthode est infaillible la campagne
électorale pour les nuls un livre érigé
au rang de code électoral du slogan de
campagne au débat télévisé en passant
par le style vestimentaire il faut
penser à tout car une cravate de travers
et c'est toute une crédibilité qui
s'effondre même si la pluie nous
accompagne aujourd'hui alors bien sûr
hors de question de vous raconter
l'issue de cette campagne mais nous
rachel kahn et xavier gorce on se pose
une question
votre récit décalé et ils le reflet
fidèle de nos moeurs politiques en
france à vous la parole
bonsoir axel kahn soins et bonsoir des
gorges merci infiniment d'être là c'est
absolument savoureux ce un pur régal ce
roman graphique j'ai appelé ça comme ça
c'est une histoire avec des dessins ses
plus beaux plus d'ifc différents qu'une
bande dessinée alors qu'est ce qui vous
a donné envie à tous les deux de de
raconter l'histoire de guy marchand avec
un t fal de nougaro en tord est entouré
d'amis fidèles qui se lance dans la
course à la présidentielle que j'avais
envie peut-être du fait de mon parcours
aussi c'est vrai que depuis 2003 j'étais
en cabinet politique j'ai fait beaucoup
de campagnes électorales et que j'avais
envie peut-être d'un peu plus de
légèreté dans notre période qui est bien
sombre et bien violente donc de raconter
une campagne un peu à la manière du
petit nicolas avec cette candeur leur
naïveté là vous connaissiez déjà tous
les deux c'est rachel qui vous a proposé
ce projet oui je crois je crois pas
qu'ils aient eu de pressions politiques
et alors c'est qui ce guy marchand parce
que c'est pas le crooner même si on a
l'impression que forcément voilà vous
l'avez choisi aussi cet homonyme papaux
a pas par hasard c'est un chômeur
sympathique il a trahi dans une banque
et un peu looser il y la constitution
dans les trams de temps mais cros tout
le temps vous le connaissez dans la
vraie vie 2 qui est de qui vous êtes
inspiré je me suis inspiré de pour lui
alors pour lui c'est vrai que c'est
l'anti héros parfait et puis c'est un
peu nous tous ses recoins on a envie
d'être utile pour notre société on ne
sait pas trop comment faire on est aussi
parfois dans des moments de solitude du
marchand a perdu sa grand mère il sait
plus quoi faire de sa vive redonner un
sens à sa vie et s'engager pour son pays
et après juste un petit clin d'oeil à
cette homonymie parce que j'ai une
homonyme qui s'appelle rachel kahn et on
oui c'est une année c'est qui déjà c'est
la femme de jean françois kahn voilà
absolument une productrice heures il est
très bien entouré il a plein d'amis guy
marchand il ya valérie la communicante
qui veut me dire un mot de valérie
valérie c'est le pur produit de de la
communication elle parle de la beaucoup
de théorie elle se réfère en permanence
effectivement ce livre dont vous avez
parlé qui est là la campagne pour les
nuls et elle terrorise tout elle est
persuadée d'avoir la martingale pour
réussir la campagne mais elle avertit un
d'emblée attention un homme blanc sans
enfant pas déconstruit qui va passer à
la moulinette des journalistes ça va
être très compliqué pour guy marchand
vie il n'a pas d'atouts effectivement
pour guy marchand qui a donc cet homme
blanc de plus de 50 ans elle le prévient
qu effectivement il va faire qu'il se
déconstruisent et que peut-être que les
autres ont beaucoup plus d'atouts que
lui elle lui dit un vraiment à lui donne
des règles de communication
les trois cc communication cohérence
coexister jeu n'importe quoi et et c'est
en fait comme en étant cette ce monde-là
de l'ultra communication du buzz donc
elle va chercher aussi à créer des buzz
par les réseaux sociaux il faut
absolument cliver en permanence il ya
maxime aussi qui s'impose comme
directeur de campagne lui c'est le plus
jeune il a 28 ans il ne quitte ni sa
mère ni les études et puis il ya gérard
le mandataire financier il ya charles le
conseiller spécial et puis hier fanta
fanta alors vous l'avez franchement
dessiner ses rachats gabon au nom du
truc dans là on va dire dans la coiffure
un petit et un petit dieu parce que je
me suis dit que guy marchand commis des
amis dhr african c'était un petit clin
d'oeil c'est pas pour vous guy marchand
vous avez gorce n'a je sais pas ça fait
de l'inde et rachel si elle a pensé à
moi pour guy marchand mais ce n'est pas
tout à fait certain
à l'as villepinte c'est le bar qui va
leur servir de qg elle envoie bouler
aussi toutes les assignations voulait
lui faire jouer à fond talent le rôle de
la diversité dans la campagne et là ça
lui plaît pas twiss et valérie la
directrice de communication qui veut lui
faire jouer ce rôle là et ça ne lui
plaît absolument pas absolument à
l'essai d'une femme libre fanta et
surtout c'est une femme qui ne comprend
pas comment se déroule cette campagne
avec ce bouquin la campagne pour les
nuls sterk en fait ce décalage entre
finalement les figures imposées d'une
campagne le qg le slogan des affiches et
ce qui peut se passer dans la vraie vie
et pour le besoin des vrais gens et
comment vous avez trouvé le parce que
c'est pas du tout les uns jibril s'est
pas du tout les pingouins comment vous
avez trouvé le trait mais il a fallu
chercher un petit peu bien évidemment
pour poser les personnages quand on
passe d'un texte il ya un peu de
descriptions nez et puis on a on a pas
mal changé parce que j'ai envoyé des
croquis rachel en lui demandant est-ce
que c'est comme ça que tu vois
fantasque que c'est comme ça que tu vois
guy etc et puis petit à petit on a cerné
un petit peu les personnages et ils ont
fini par trouver un petit peu leur
équilibre alors il ya toi ils ont accusé
ils ont imprimé des tracts une affiche
qui sont à fond sur les réseaux sociaux
la riposte il a un programme ou pas
à force de vouloir imposer le slogan est
plein de choses les tracts et bien écrit
pas forcément le temps en fait mais il a
son programme intérieur quand même c'est
vrai que moi j'ai eu ben il a axé
beaucoup évidemment sur la création sur
la culture sur les questions aussi
d'universalisme d'humanisme mais en fait
son programme c'est la constitution oui
c'est ça mais ne veut pas forcément
changé et en tout cas son programme
aussi c'est beaucoup de questions c'est
à dire qu'en fait voilà c'est sur les
postes beaucoup de caisses il se pose
beaucoup de questions parce qu'ils
pensent que les réponses sont parfois
plus dans les questions que dans des
réponses toutes faites du politique et
il a il a un slogan alors un gros gros
brainstorming vous retrouver son slogan
qu'est-ce que on aboutit sur de
l'efficace on donne le slogan se révèle
pas on regarde ça finalement jean mais
finalement ça voilà ça marche parce que
c'est clair et c'est efficace il est
complètement décalé en fait il y a un
peu manipulé aussi un accent qui joue le
jeu mais à un moment il dit stop
pourquoi je suis pas suis pas énarque
j'ai pas fait sciences po mais je suis
pas pour autant l'idiot du village je
crois que c'est un personnage qui est un
peu comme tout les tous les gens qui ont
des projets qui croit avoir un projet
qui croit avoir un programme
s'aperçoivent qu'ils n'en n'ont pas
partir du mot il commence à le mettre en
oeuvre et je crois qu'on voit beaucoup
ça quand on en croit voir au travail le
matin avec une idée qui lui semblent
génial on s'aperçoit que la difficulté
c'est vrai pour la création artistique
de la même façon c'est le le la
difficulté c'est de passer à la
production et là je crois que c'est le
saurais si c'est un peu le récit d'une
errance
de vacuité de la politique dans le
message de la bd oui tout à fait et puis
moi je voulais interroger surtout à
toutes les questions qu'on a pu vivre
l'abstention c'est cette dichotomie
presque entre les citoyens et les
personnes qui qui sont politiques voilà
même si tout le monde doit être
politique aujourd'hui en vrai et donc
c'est ça cette équipe là elle se
construit du terrain et elle s'improvise
finalement politico oui d'un côté il ya
cette candeur il est décalé mais d'un
autre côté les choses qu'il porte à mon
avis ce sont des choses fondamentales
qu'on a trop oublié le rapport à
l'humain est par exemple ouais le
rapport à l'humain le rapport à nos
relations
aussi cette manière de il veut aller
partout en france il veut être sur tout
l'ensemble des générations et pas
simplement voir les aînés d'un côté la
jeunesse de l'autre alors que valérie
habib ici il faut des jeunes il faut des
jeunes membres voilà non mais c'est
extrêmement drôle franchement nous voilà
intérieurement à toutes les pages il
donne pas de leçons mais en même temps
voilà il s'agrippe à ce qu'on lui dit de
faire cesser la dictature du buzz aussi
qui est dénoncé dans ce livre c'est
l'idée oui il ya beaucoup de choses qui
sont dénoncés je crois
le buzz le le les figures obligées aussi
d'une campagne il ya des choses qui
paraissent un petit peu artificielle
quand on veut faire des marchés quand on
veut des potes distribué des tracts
aller chez l'habitant etc il ya toutes
ces choses là qui sont
présentés bouquet qui on reconnaît tout
les toutes les toutes les figures de
style d'une campagne
aujourd'hui d'authenticité c'était en
fait on part effectivement presque de ce
livre qui n'existe pas je crois une
campagne électorale pour les nuls alors
même qu'il faudrait partir véritablement
du sens que l'on veut donner à son
projet par ailleurs c'est vrai qu'on a
différents partis politiques qui au fond
respecte tous les mêmes règles et ses
étranges normalement normalement quand
on a un fond il doit correspondre à une
certaine forme je pense qu'il faut
réinterroger aujourd'hui la forme de la
politique
d'accords avec la corse alors qu'athènes
pourrait prendre comme nouvelle forme
c'est à dire en fait je pense que
notamment bien c'était pour une campagne
présidentielle
en fait c'est s'interroger d'abord avec
les personnes qui vont faire cette
campagne et s'interroger sur ce qu'on a
envie de 2,2 montrez moi je pense que la
question par exemple de la solitude
aujourd'hui est une question
fondamentale et femmes est abordée
vraiment ramé alors même qu'on a eue le
coc vide alors même qu'on a eue avec
avec nos aînés mais aussi nos
adolescents et nos jeunes qui ont été
sacrément impacts et des gens qui ne
parlent quasiment à personne dans la
journée ce guy marchand il est seul
quand il commence sa campagne électorale
parce qu'il est seul et donc cette
campagne là c'est un alibi pour trouver
une équipe autour de lui de retrouver
ses amis et d'avoir une bataille commune
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il faudrait
mettre l'accent sur sa wii on a perdu le
sens de l'engagement et le d'une
communauté communaux d'intérêt général
et ceux qui alors rachel kahn je peux
pas ne pas vous demander ça parce que il
fait de la politique vous en faites
aussi oui vous en faites vous en avez
fait chez les écolos et on vous a vu au
comité de soutien d' emmanuel macron
vous savez votre nom circule pour la
culture pour entrer au gouvernement ça
vous plairait vous me demandez si matin
j'y pense en me rasant saissac homme qui
marche c'est vous demande alors qu'on
voit là où on sait que les va et vient
entre matignon et l'elysée sont
incessants on s'attend à l'annoncé du
gouvernement demain si vous aimeriez
faire de la politique dans ce
gouvernement moi j'en fais en fait le
truc c'est que je
vous le savez depuis un an quand je sers
mon pays depuis 20 ans et ça je sers mon
pays j'écris je joue je suis engagé dans
cette notion engagé dans cette campagne
est en fait je continuerai alors pas
quoi qu'il en coûte mais quoi qu'il
arrive c'est à dire que si on vous
appelle vous dites quoi je ne refuserai
pas mais je suis chrétien vous appellera
fecan je vous rentrer au gouvernement
vous détruit oui parce que vous savez
d'où je viens c'est déjà en fait
simplement les bruits de couloir et la
rue les rumeurs etc de là où je suis
parti avec mon pedigree la joie la
colonisation l'immigration c'est déjà
quelque chose mais moi mon objectif
c'est de servir mon pays pourquoi macron
parce que parce que je me reconnais je
me reconnais en fait dans dans son
combat pour l'humanisme et
l'universalisme aussi la francophonie
mais aussi la fibre artistique et
culturelle qui peut porter et bien merci
merci pour ces confidences rachel kahn
une partie de campagne c'est drôle et
c'est très touchant à la fois regards
croisés entre une essayiste un
dessinateur c'est aux éditions de
l'observatoire vous avez compris il faut
lire allez c'est l'heure d'accueillir
pour terminer cette émission nous
affranchit pour leur parti pris ce soir
el amoud un gars va pour son carnet de
campagne des législatives comme tous les
soirs fatiha gac gujarat qui va revenir
sur la sphère tabassé puis isabelle
lasserre qui va nous parler ce soir de
la reddition des soldats ukrainien des
héros d'azov tallulah franchi et ef st
les voici bonsoir mesdames ravi de vous
retrouver au soir de son fidèle et elsa
ont commencé avec vous parle dans ces
législatives que vous chronique et au
quotidien d'un retrait celui de jérôme
peyrat il n'est plus candidat ensemble
en dordogne après une journée très
compliqué sous le feu des critiques oui
mais ramon var dérouler un peu le fil de
cette journée même si la polémique elle
couvait depuis quelques jours elle a
pris une ampleur particulière ce matin
cette affaire elle concerne jérôme
peyrat candidat donc de la majorité
présidentielle en dordogne jérôme peyrat
ce n'est pas n'importe qui c'est un
homme qui vient de la droite il a été
conseiller de nicolas sarkozy puis
conseiller d'emmanuel macron et jérôme
peyrat bien il a été condamné en 2020
pour des faits de violences conjugales
condamné à une amende avec sursis alors
son investiture interpelle voilà comment
se justifie ou tentent plutôt de se
justifier le délégué général de la
république en marche stanislas guérini
il était ce matin au micro de nos
confrères de france info
je dis que c'est parfois un peu plus
complexe de la façon dont sont présentés
les choses si j'avais mais la correction
ou même le soupçon qu'on ait affaire à
quelqu'un qui puisse être violent et
coupable de violences sur les femmes
jamais non mais que j'aurai avec ses
investitures là alors cette défense elle
est très critiqué notamment parmi les
militantes féministes mais pas que toute
la journée les médias sont en boucle la
pression médiatique politique sociale
est trop forte à 17 heures jérôme peyrat
non salle agence france presse qui est
le retire sa candidature
et dans la foulée stanislas guérini
publiant communiqué un communiqué en
forme de mea culpa et il parle d'une
décision commune jusqu'à présent si je
me trompe pas les à cette candidature
elle n'avait pas vraiment susciter
d'émotion la majorité n 191 pas ému
alors certains députés avec quand même
eu du mal à comprendre cette investiture
mais notamment parce que pour investir
jérôme peyrat et bien il a fallu shooter
le terme n'est pas très joli mais c'est
celui qui est employé et bien la députée
sortante jacqueline du bois ce qui est
un peu étonnant c'est que aucun
responsable de la majorité n'a vu n'a
pris conscience que cette investiture
pouvait poser problème en terme de
symbole et même côté députés aujourd'hui
pour en parler on réclamait souvent le
triple enfin pour dénoncer une connerie
pourquoi ce silence radio est bien parce
que s'en prendre à cette ce choix
d'investiture c'est un peu s'en prendre
à celui qui on l'a tellement raconté les
validé une par une
président de la république emmanuel
macron alors quelle est la règle
précisément là en l'espèce jérôme peyrat
c'est une condamnation judiciaire il ya
aussi peut-être des cas de figure avec
des procédures en cours la loi fixe les
règles ou c'est ont beau vouloir des
partis alors il n'y a pas vraiment de
règle à part s'il ya eu une peine
d'inéligibilité
sinon rien interdit d'investir un
candidat qui a été condamné il ya cinq
ans vous vous souvenez peut-être mais
lors de la loi de moralisation il avait
peut-être été question d'avoir un casier
judiciaire vierge cette option avait été
abandonné dans la majorité vous l'avais
dit il ya plusieurs candidats qui ont
été réinvestis qui ont des procédures
judiciaires en cours jusqu'à présent
c'est la présomption d'innocence qui
prévaut dit jusqu'à présent parce qu'on
voit bien que dans certaines affaires
notamment quand il s'agit de violences
sexuelles ou sexistes il ya une pression
sociale qui est très forte et qui
demande à mettre en retrait quand on a
des accusations et pas forcément une
condamnation merci beaucoup à la
transition toute trouvée si j'ose dire
avec vous pas tia et une petite relance
alors pardonnez moi une petite des
relances pour vous demander une dernière
petite info est la toute petite info
très rapidement marion maréchal sera
candidate mais elle sera suppléant anton
souvient elle est sortie de sa retraite
politique pour rejoindre eric zemmour
l'ennemi juré toute attente elle sera
donc la suppléante de stanislas rigaud
qui n'est pas n'importe qui c'est le
président de génération z elle ira dans
la 2e circonscription du vaucluse elle
avait été élue députée mais dans celle
d'à côté la troisième c'est très clair
merci aux âges tenais ma transition mais
la voici fatiha voulait revenir ce soir
sur la ferte aboaf ce militant
journaliste qui avait reçu l'investiture
de la nuque baisse et qui s'est
finalement retirée voilà moi c'est
plutôt la complaisance dont il a fait
l'objet par la sfi qui m'intéressait
parce que c'est clairement son identité
de wesh wesh de quartier keenan
nécessaire surjouée qui plaisait à la
hi-fi et quand on regarde le reste des
candidats qu'ils ont investit partout en
france on comprend qu'ils avaient besoin
d'un haras pour cacher la forêt de tous
les bourgeois blanc des centres villes
qu'ils présentent alors qu'ils n'ont que
le mot diversité renouvellement à la
bouche ils ne connaissent pas les
quartiers populaires et ne fréquentent
pas les habits ils les fantasmes c'est
du culturalisme là ils ont débranché la
candidature de tabous apps mais en fait
c'est sa radicalité sa violence dès
l'origine à l'encontre de charlie hebdo
à l'encontre de la france à l'encontre
d'israël à l'encontre de la police c'est
cette violence et cette radicalité là
qui aurait dû lui valoir d'être
débranchés et ce côté fantasmes qu'ils
ont en l'estimant représentatif des
habitants des quartiers populaires en
dit long sur les stéréotypes qu'il
véhicule voyez comme ils nous voient
alors clémentine autain et sandrine
rousseau ont expliqué leur démarche
d'accompagnement des victimes au sein de
de la nuque et de la france insoumise
dans cette cellule qui est chargé de
recueillir la parole des victimes un
parti politique un je ne parle pas de la
justice clémentine autain a dit que
l'afer a été réglé rapidement en cinq
jours seulement il ya d'autres partis
renaissance on en parlait ainsi un
instant avec la sphère jérôme peyrat là
c'est une condamnation différentes pour
violences conjugales il a fini par se
parent se retirer oui sous la pression
et c'est l'autre élément qui découlent
de ce relativisme
c'est
la différence la dénonciation à
géométrie variable des violences
sexuelles et sexistes d'à côté vous
aurez les vrais coupables les coupables
d'office les coupables à 100% et puis de
l'autre côté n'est pas vraiment coupable
un petit peu responsable est en fait ce
qui déterminera si vous relevez de la
première de la deuxième catégorie c'est
votre origine ethnique ou votre camp
politique ce n'est plus l'acte ainsi on
avait un exemple avait en la personne du
chanteur quant à un artiste de gauche
comme cantat qui a pu rallier refaire la
une d z'arts occupe cible a fait preuve
d'une l'objet d'une mansuétude
incroyable imaginez si sardou qui avait
cogné à mort sa campagne en sa compagnie
on n'aurait pas eu le même résultat si
vous êtes racisées par contre on va
sommer c'est comme ça que les gens aient
interprété le traitement par la hi-fi on
va sommer les femmes de se taire de ne
pas porter plainte pour ne pas nourrir
apporter de l'eau au moulin de l'extrême
droite et pour vous montrer deux
exemples concrets il suffit de regarder
les deux tweets qui vont paraître à
l'écran et damien jacquemin voilà le
premier et c'est un proche de pierre
jacquemin
qui est journaliste un proche de
clémentine ôta et qui reprend des
éléments de sa tribune où elle explique
que finalement puisque la justice est
défaillante on peut comprendre que
certaines femmes ne préfère pas y faire
appel le deuxième tweet est encore plus
choquant c'est fait par quelqu'un qui
est très calme vent en poupe qui devient
influenceurs et qui se présente comme
indigéniste marxiste et qui parle de
masculinité indigènes et que donc on ne
comprend pas les masculinités indigènes
qui se traduirait par des actes de
violence à et qu'il faut être un peu
plus compréhensifs et on retrouve là le
problème de l'intersexualité qui
fonctionne comme un immense céder le
passage les femmes doivent céder le
passage doivent se taire par rapport aux
hommes de la communauté et on retrouve
le cas par exemple nina simone aretha
franklin qui étaient battues par leur
mari est en fait puisque ont considéré
que les hommes noirs étaient dévirilisé
par la ségrégation raciale c'était
normal d'accepter qui battent leurs
femmes parce qu'il pouvait retrouver
comme ça un peu de virilité c'est pas
notre conception en france qui paie ça
permet de réaffirmer une dernière fois
et encore une fois que l'universalisme
c'est d'abord un féminisme alors
j'aimerais savoir si vous vous souhaitez
vous que dans la sphère tm boîte la
justice soit saisie parce que ça n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
faut que la justice soit de plus en plus
efficace et ça ne fonctionnera que si on
fait appel à elle et surtout quel est le
discours contient aux femmes depuis des
années de ne plus se taire de porter
plainte et de faire reconnaître leur
qualité de victime leur statut donc bien
sûr je veux avec la présomption
d'innocence mais il pourra se défendre
mais ces femmes et balle ovale et
jusqu'au bout de leur démarche merci
merci fatiha isabelle ce soir voulait
revenir sur la situation en ukraine ce
mot de reddition il est lourd de sens
c'est cette reddition des soldats
ukrainien lusine azoff talent il était à
bout de forces et à bout de vivre ils
ont été obligés de se rendre ils ont
quand même tenu tête trois mois aux
forces russes est ce qu'on peut dire
qu'ils ont transformée d'une certaine
façon la défaite de mario paul en succès
oui alors bien sûr c'est une défaite
militaire et ce n'est pas la question
ils ont dû
quitter marioupol mais dans l'histoire
myriam il ya pas mal de défaites
militaires qui sont considérés comme des
comme des victoires je n'en citerai
qu'une parce que elle a eu lieu en
1389 c'est la défaite des forces serbes
contre l' empire ottoman dans un champ
qui s'appelle le champ des merles et
dans le kosovo actuelle est aujourd'hui
encore les serbes considèrent toujours
cette défaite comme comme une victoire
ce que la guerre ne repose pas seulement
sur les armements militaires mais aussi
sur la volonté est là aussi une
dimension psychologique et en résistant
de manière aussi acharnée pendant trois
mois dans l' usine de marioupol prêts
sacrifier leur vie pour défendre la
ville des combattants de d'azov stahl
ont fourni à la résistance ukrainienne
est au pouvoir ukrainienne les héros
dont il avait besoin pour galvaniser le
pays et les combattants est aujourd'hui
en tout cas les congeler combattre les
les ukrainiens considère que la la
défense de héroïque de marioupol a
carrément changé le cours de la guerre
donc pour vous c'est clairement une
victoire en trompe l'oeil de la russie
et ben oui ça c'est le c'est l'envers de
la médaille bien sûr marioupol est une
victoire pour l'armée russe puisqu'elle
s'en est emparé et que grâce à ça elle
contrôle désormais la toute la bande
côtière et qu'elle pourra présenter
mario paul comme une victoire à la
population à la population russe la
propagande ans fera ses choux gras mais
à quel prix l'armée russe et l'armée
russe et hérite d'une ville complètement
détruite qui ressemble à vue kovar
pendant le le la guerre en
ex-yougoslavie
par ailleurs la mario paul a révélé les
faiblesses de l'armée russe et la
désorganisation de cette armée russe et
grâce à leur résistance à charnay les
centres et le craignaient en fait à
fixer pendant trois mois les unités
russes qui n'ont pas pu aller à leur
infliger de 2,2 de profonds dégâts et
ses unités russes n'ont pas pu aller
attaquer d'autres villes c'est peut-être
pour ça d'ailleurs que kev n'est pas
traité n'était pas tombé donc on a les
ukrainiens ont réussi à limiter les
pertes des pertes et l'impact l'impact
de l'armée russe qu'est ce qu'ils vont
devenir maintenant c'est ses soldats les
installe alors c'est la grande question
ils sont a priori quasiment tous sortis
ils ont été conduits
en zone russe normalement ils sont
censés être traités comme des
prisonniers de guerre il ya eu un accord
avec le cicr le comité international de
la croix rouge le président volodymyr
zelensky s'est personnellement impliqué
dans leur sauvetage c'est vraiment très
très important pour lui c'est lui qui
leur avait demandé d'arrêter de combat
parce que disait-il il nous faut nos
héros vivent donc normalement il espère
le président ukrainien pouvoir les
échanger contre un nombre peut-être
supérieur période ailleurs de deux
prisonniers russes on n'en sait rien en
tout cas à l'assemblée russe la douma
certains considèrent que ces ses ennemis
les légendes azoff qui sont considérés
comme des nazis par la propagande russe
mérite un sort plus radicale
on verra bien merci beaucoup merci à
l'aide a franchi demain un remaniement
reza demain vendredi et toute façon on
ne sait jamais rien on espère d'ici la
fin de la semaine mais l'avocat vous
serez l'aller paris s'était plus pour
vendredi que je n'en dors et puis je
vous dire l inverse demande allez
merci merci beaucoup c'est la fin de
cette émission tout de suite votre
soirée documentaire avec un inédit juge
et patron un nom au tribunal de commerce
de marseille très belle soirée et à
demain
[Musique]